new growth for the cadence community as
another smith's marketplace opens
tomorrow located at lake mead and warm
springs mary jane belliesa takes us to
henderson how locals are responding with
this expansion
[Music]
smith's marketplace on east lake mead is
gearing up to open its doors this
weekend this is the second smiths to
open up in east henderson catering to
the cadence community and residents say
it's much needed john carpenter has
lived in henderson for six years and
says the changes are clear to see it
seemed to be kind of like the missing
link was the retail row
and now that it's happening it was
always promised whenever we first got
out here and you know you wait until it
happens and now it's happening which is
great to see cheryl gowen vice president
of cadence marketing as a secluded area
and location is a big appeal for
residents cadence is a great example of
the expansion of henderson nevada we
have 2200 acres here and we have more
than 3 300 families calling cadence home
so this smith marketplace out here is
just a tremendous asset with homes
averaging around 300 000 henderson
realtor trish nash says new retail
development can help increase the
property value of nearby homes the
residents
are just
very very grateful because now we have
our own beautiful beautiful
um store here and there's just going to
be tremendous growth with all that's
going to be happening right within that
center with the shops that are going to
be there and
wells fargo and cafe rio and starbucks
abriana martindale smith's corporate
affairs manager says this new location
will provide convenience we'll be happy
to be able to offer this new service to
them but additionally we were able to
add 230 jobs to this position so we're
excited to be a part of the henderson
community mary jane vallieza live local
now